luego de una noche y una mañana de calma
se reaviva el fuego cruzado entre Israel
y gasa lo que vuelve a amenazar los
diálogos que intentan poner fin a los
combates 13 horas pasaron para que
volvieran a sonar las alarmas al
mediodía en comunidades israelíes en
linderas a la franja y en asentamientos
de las montañas al sur de Jerusalén un
área que hasta ahora no había sido
objetivo de los proyectiles de la yihad
islámica Palestina uno de esos cohetes
se cayó en una zona abierta del
asentamiento de Sión entre broni Belén
en las y Jordania ocupada de inmediato
Israel reanudó sus bombardeos contra
objetivos de la sijada en gaza el
ejército israelí asegura que en estos
cuatro días de la llamada operación
escudo y flecha han destruido más de 200
instalaciones de la hija de islámica y
han matado a ochos altos mandos del
grupo en tanto el Ministerio de salud de
gasas señala que la cifra de Muertos
palestinos supera la treintena con al
menos 15 civiles seis de ellos niños y
más de 90 personas heridas a esto hay
que sumarle la muerte de un israelí por
el impacto de un cohete ayer en un
edificio de aparta de rejobot todo esto
domina las expectativas puestas en las
conversaciones para un cese al fuego
reactivadas en la madrugada por Egipto
según medios israelíes el gobierno de
benjamine Peña Gula anunció al Cairo un
freno en las negociaciones tras estos
cohetes lanzados al área de Jerusalén
Mientras tanto dos organizaciones de
israelíes de Derechos Humanos
contactaron al ministro de defensa Job
galán para pedirle que se abra el cruce
de Jerez para gassatines que tienen
tratamientos médicos en Israel según
estos organismos son 292 personas se
vieron privadas de la atención en estos
cuatro días entre ellas 15 que requieren
atención inmediata